what's up YouTube we're going to show
you right now how to do a property on a
rent to rent basis with no freaking
money because you found this decent deal
today um Adam so this property and what
was it about this house that made you
think it could be a good rent to rent
the area is primed the location is so
good it's really quiet there's a lot of
construction work there's a lot of like
army barracks and things and a lot of
people that actually come for like shots
stairs around the area you've got two
already two rentals yeah two in
Liverpool and we wanted to expand so
this is where we're coming into what is
a rental rent how does it how does the
model work for anyone doesn't know so a
rent to rent model is where you rent a
property from a landlord and you pay
them their monthly rent um I'll see a
breed up front you then rent out on a
room by room basis to local contractors
hospital staff and that's how you make
your profit rent it out rent it out of
Haram out cash flow baby cash flow is
king So question is you need obviously
the landlord's concerned you spoke to
him so I've been here I spoke to the
landlord himself who is 93 and his
granddaughter who is also involved and
her husband as well the landlord is well
open to it but the other two when I
spoke to their granddaughter last time
she was very reserved so I'm not sure
how this one is gonna go but how much
money are you guys got ready for this
deal how much money you want to put into
this so we don't want to put anything in
it today
I'm sorry we're gonna try and negotiate
but it's asking for 1600 pound rent so
you're planning to knock him down a bit
on the rent yeah yeah
um zero rent up front yeah no deposit no
deposit how much profit will you make if
he says yes if we go on the rental of a
1600 which is asking for I'm looking at
about 180 to 200 a night which at 70
would make around 1500 after bills and
everything as well so this third one
would basically be Financial Freedom
yeah
if we need to get this through the road
[Music]
I mean like what's the plan what are you
planning on doing with the bedrooms at
the minute we'd be looking at
potentially coming into here this being
a zip bed so potentially yeah and it is
two there's two beds so you can sleep
two people in here
yeah there's a lot of space it's like
four four big rooms three bathrooms as
well so so you do would you be doing
this as like
no HMR you know service accommodation
yeah renting what the whole house are we
I think with the aim is to rent the
whole house out yeah with
um certain certain um schemes out there
for contractors and things like that
that I think we're going to try and
Target students so there's something
like cozy workers and tread stairs and
things like that and you think they'd
pay about 180 a night it depends on the
amount of people it's probably about 35
pound ahead per night so if you in this
property itself we can get two people in
here two people in the other bedroom
[Music]
how confident are you that you'd be able
to make this profitable and with with
the with the numbers that we've looked
at the pretty like 80 90 confident I
think that it's going to be an amazing
property how do you put a break clause
in the contract yeah there's a brick
collar in there but um so we've got six
months of
um before we get the break clause and
could you lease the furniture yeah so
what we're actually doing is
um we've talked about this with a guy
who's also on the academy with us who's
gonna fund it at a 10 APR fixed so he's
gonna Finance the furniture yeah so
we're not actually putting it we're
putting any money into the furniture so
the only thing you're gonna have to pay
is upfront rent yeah and deposit which
you're thinking you're gonna we're gonna
try and negotiate another person what
we're going to try and do today yeah how
much how much profit Dan do you thinking
from your numbers
you'd make on that uh so we'll seventy
percent occupancy we should be able to
achieve sort of 14 1500 pounds a month
you've already got your two rentals that
you just secured last month
and yeah so this is this is going to be
like a really really good addition to
our portfolio as well and the facts as
well that with the fact the Furnishing
and the financing a bit of that if we
can get that money then there's
something a government scheme at the
minute a super tax we get 100 actually
130 of the asset back on expenses so
even though we're paying 10 APR getting
30 back on the government scheme with
it's really so I like it I think it
worked we need to get a deal yeah yeah
let's do it
everything all right with my heart lap
yeah
of course by the way these guys I've
seen them up broke before they're very
professional so in terms of like getting
everything out do we need to empty
episodes I've spoke to Roman about this
I'm gonna come in and um help when when
needed and we can go through things and
whatnot that we want to keep and stuff
that I only live like 20 minutes away so
I can behave when needed to to help with
the furniture and stuff like that
because the main things for us obviously
like the the white good stuff and
whatnot in there your fridge your
microwaves and toasters all them if we
can keep them amazing but apparently you
want the kettle or something out of the
microwave do you want the toaster so
they are doing the work yeah well doing
work at yardage guns the contract times
what happens to that work obviously like
certain things would be doing would be
like maybe changing the bathroom so it's
a little bit more modernized I'll paint
in the walls like and things like that
so anything that we do is in our best
interest to make it like as good looking
as possible basically which is at the
end of the day is only going to be not
beneficial for you so people like like
yourself kind of like um really good
looking
like so people that are doing contract
work and things like that because it's
such a secure area with the garage and
everything as well so it's not gonna be
amazing like we use that for marketing
but it's not Airbnb we turn we because
that would be like short-term stays like
one night let's things like that we tend
to work on a three night minimum so it's
anyone that's staying for like normally
Monday to Friday is our primary Market
getting contractors and people like that
in yourself okay amazing
[Music]
that one's your contracts that's all
signed there's a front door
one is for that door and that one's the
back door there as well amazing what
about kind of when we first chatted and
stuff what was about the agreement
itself kind of like were you drawn to
what did you like about it when we first
chatted I mean I've had the right of
looking after the house so I told her if
I can
give it to somebody else that would be
great yeah yeah
and three years yeah sorry that was
screwed yeah yeah because obviously we
put together a three year agreement
didn't we and yeah though and the fact
that I was I would be getting a similar
to rent yeah to what I would be getting
just letting the household without the
um problems associated with the
changeover restaurants yeah I guess
you're getting the security that if you
had a tenant in here for the longer term
then you wouldn't be in and checking it
all the time would you wear is like when
we come in we're getting people in to
check it and clean it every single week
also I was quite impressed by your
attitude oh no I appreciate that
appreciate that a lot but yeah it's like
it's this is a like doing what we do
with proper in things like as a people
game like referrals who wants to be a
win-win for everybody involved isn't it
so well it's nice when you see somebody
who is really a professional and I think
you are yes I appreciate that yeah
that's that's the that's the goal I mean
it's sitting it's in business we want to
help people we want to give them the
rent they want to make sure that their
properties are looked after and again
done it in the best professional way
possible so
yeah yes and I really appreciate it it's
definitely going to be a win-win that
was sick these guys are beasts been in
the game three months
beasts let's go absolutely great what
just happened oh it's secured it's done
in there done deal we got it so if you
paid no deposit he hasn't asked for any
references
oh I think the reason he didn't ask for
references was because he just trusted
they could trust you guys yeah what
about the granddaughter and the partner
oh they were they were tough they were
tough to go but they weren't that what
about asking about Airbnb and yeah oh my
goodness hmm how do you feel guys I
built like this it just wasn't that
little that little jingle there he's
doing everything for me right now oh man
done in your pleased over the moon it
kind of puts into context what we've
sort of been building to over the last
three months since joining the academy
yeah yeah to understand getting momentum
first night it's like yeah it's like you
say it's that once like that snowball
starts to go down the hill and it just
gets bigger and bigger getting that
first yes the first deal of the line the
last month was like it's such a relief
but it's one point we've got three now
so yeah invited things into like the
training the stuff that you you teach us
at the through the academy and the
training and stuff coming up overcoming
all the objections and things like that
it's like it's game changing because if
you come to this without the knowledge
without the the training and stuff like
that it's you can do it like you you
will get a deal eventually but
if you don't know what to say if you
don't know what level of objections are
going to be then
it's really hard to put into practice
and I mostly I've got to say like I've
had about a thousand no's and we've got
three yeses but about a thousand Nils
and every single time a new objection
comes up or a new way someone word is it
words it it's it's about how you that's
a lesson need to learn that yeah it's
like my favorite saying is bail like
it's not you haven't failed it's your
first attempt in learning if you use it
as an abbreviation yeah well like I love
that saying I think that every single
time I get off a phone call where it's a
no I'm thinking that yeah that was an
attempt in learning Adam or just simply
learning and how did so how did you guys
decide to partner partner up and what
what's that what's the story there
so basically we met on the first press
course in Bradford and June time I think
it was wasn't it yeah um we didn't
actually speak on that corset did we no
no I remember I actually acknowledged
you until it's all about the the other
side of the room yeah that goes
confidence so then when we um we both
signed up for the um Dill Finance
traffic and didn't we yeah I could have
been on that course
um and then we actually
um just sort of found an Airbnb together
yeah um to explain I know cool yeah
because they were like us and there were
like five other people that we all had
an Airbnb together cut down costs a
little bit just everybody else in the
Airbnb would just like chill on an
evening like I'll go to bed and whatever
and then there's me and Dan sat on the
table until two o'clock in the morning
looking at deals and trying to find
stuff with it so what profit are you
expecting from this now and the other
two rent events that you've got because
they're live now aren't they yeah yeah
so we've got one that's at 70 percent
around 800 900 profit then the other one
is around 1300 and then this one at 80
should be around 1500 so we do the maths
on that quickly we've got it's about
three three and a half Grand injury and
a half Grand a month yeah awesome
amazing yeah yeah so for where we're at
right now and that's again it's one deal
away from us both kind of been
financially free right now incredible if
I'm setting this up
so now then we need to get this property
Spruce stop yeah we need to get your
furniture guy to invest in the furniture
yeah we need to get this on Airbnb we've
got how many weeks before we have to do
that before we have to stop paying the
guy rent because we've got four weeks
now just shy four weeks before we've got
to get this done and ready to go but
still got four weeks to do with furnish
get it ready get it marketed yeah get it
on Airbnb yeah
so Samuel asked me to show you guys
around the property and how we've done
so welcome to my crib come on in and so
as you'll see we have massively
renovated this property we have turned
it from almost looking a little bit
probate we've worked with the landlord
on this and we'll turn this property
into something amazing and as you can
see from the essay point of view it
looks really really good really really
modern and there's a lot of people that
are going to want to stay here with a
big Surplus to Harrogate City Center as
well Cash Flow side of things around 70
to 80 occupants who are expecting to be
hitting around 3 400 pound uh turnover a
month which will leave us with about
that kind of 1500 pound Mark profit I
learned how to do all of this by
attending one of Samuel's courses I
can't thank him enough about the
knowledge and the understanding he's
given me about these different
strategies within property and the fact
that we've been able to turn the one
pound from the initial cost that we went
to into a property like this is
incredible so if you are wanting to get
into property I can't recommend going to
a one pound courses enough you'll get so
much knowledge and so much value that is
very very worthwhile so I believe the
rent to rent Revolution is coming up
very very soon so make sure you book on
PR ticket and thank you Samuel for
giving us the opportunity to turn a
property like this into something
absolutely amazing
foreign